Did you get my question about using the oxalate balance for my situation?
Okay, so I didn't get that one.
So I remember there's two oxalate products, the oxalate scavenger.
Right.
If you have primary, hyperoxyluria, which is what you typically see on your genetics.
And so, okay, somebody could go, well, I don't have my genetics.
How do I know that that's it?
Well, another way to know that you probably have, or you have an increased risk for primary hyperoxyluria, is
do you have a family history of stone formation?
So if the answer is yeah, my father had kidney stones, my mother had kidney stones, my grandpa did, my uncle did, my sister did.
Pretty much it's probably primary, there's probably a genetic component.
And then I would use the oxalate scavenger.
So the oxalate balancer is to help heal, do some work to help heal the gut and divide the oxalate.
So, you don't have any history of kidney stones in your family, but, you know, you can't remember anybody in your family had kidney stones, but you did.
Maybe you want to do the oxalate balancer.
Okay, the reason why I was asking is because of my thyroid, I had one load removed like 40 years ago.
And I think during norms examination in our conversation, it came up that you said that, that oxalates inhibit T3.
Oxalates can inhibit T3, but also with thyroid issues with any thyroid issues, if anybody has thyroid issues, they should be off of gluten.
Okay, because gluten is a molecular mimic to the thyroid gland.
Okay, well, we definitely are off of gluten on this part.
Any history of stone formation for you or anything?
No, I don't have any history of that. It was just norm.
Okay, so then I don't know that I worry so much about oxalates if I were you.
Okay, all right. That's great. Thank you.